elle fait la fierté de ses enfants et de
son mari une fierté d'autant plus forte
ce jeudi 10 février 2022 il ya eu le
brin iv vient de recevoir le prix de
députés de l'année 2021 une
reconnaissance célébrer en famille la
famille ça vous permet aussi de rester
très ancré dans la réalité
et quand vous rentrez avait après une
dure journée que vous frimer avec ce qui
s'est passé souvent mes enfants me
rappel à l'ordre parce que ils ont
d'autres préoccupations
j'ai repris les médecins les courses
les dossiers scolaires avec plaisir
présidente de la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale avocate et juriste
de profession d'hebron privé s'est
engagée derrière emmanuel macron en 2010
est une femme politique issu de la
société civile un parcours récompensé
par le jury du trombinoscope
c'est quelqu'un qui arrivait de la
société civile qui étaient complètement
inconnus on va le dire au bataillon
finalement qui a fait son trou qui a
à force de pugnacité s'est imposé la
sphère politique yvelinoise était à
l'honneur lors de cette 30ème cérémonie
du trombinoscope à côté de yaël brive et
valérie pécresse a obtenu le prix de
personnalité politique de l'année 2021
c'est une première marche vers
personnalité de l'année 2022 en tout cas
c'est ce que j'espère j'espère que les
français poursuivront ils me feront
confiance cette nomination est une
reconnaissance de ses victoires
politiques obtenus en 2021 d'abord aux
élections régionales d'île de france
puis à la primaire interne des
républicains restent un défi de taille
en 2022 remporté l'élection
présidentielle en avril prochain